when the pandemic struck
um i quite
immediately began to feel like your
ubi advocacy um took on
an obviousness that had eluded me
during the campaign right um and i'll
get to why in a second
like i i feel like you were singing a
song that became very obvious to a lot
of people once you suddenly have
millions of people
from one week to the next thrown out in
the street
um losing jobs being evicted you know
it's been obvious to me and many other
people for a while you shouldn't tie
health care
to employment for example right and i
think the point you were making was that
you you shouldn't
tie employment to the rudiments of
you know human dignity living i was very
persuaded by that i was belatedly
persuaded by it because of the pandemic
i think you deserve a lot of credit
for for elevating that i'll tell you
what my lingering
non-pandemic reservation is and i'm
curious your thought then we can go to
the rest of the
the here we are now agenda um
my reservation is i think i mentioned
this in the book
that it i fear that a ubi
assumes a bleak future for ordinary
people
in a way that maybe
uh we can avoid yes yes
i fear that it concedes a point that i'm
not willing to concede
which is you know for example 40 of
people will not have regular work
whatever the numbers are right
like yeah i'm and you're more of an
expert on these actual trends than i am
for sure but i view any of those types
of outcomes
as being the product of politics not the
product of forces like i actually don't
think
like i think there is some tax regime
some regulatory regime in place
where even profound technological shifts
do not have those impacts now i don't
know if they're passable
i don't know if we're gonna do them but
part of i think part of why
and i know you coming from a very
different place but part of why the ubi
is very popular in the valley
right and a lot of those people love you
more than you love them back
is because i think what they hear in
your ubi thing
is like we'll get to continue
the current power relations of the
country
like we'll get to continue having these
monopolies
we'll get to continue having labor
precarity
so that we don't have to make uber
drivers work like and now
in a way i just worry that the
well-meaning thing
becomes almost an excuse to not change
those power equations we don't need to
fix labor law
to fight this notion of people being
made contractors instead of employees
because they'll have a ubi we don't need
to rebuild unions
because even if we don't people will be
eating and living
and i'm not sure where i land on it to
be honest
which is i think something you're not
supposed to say but like i don't know
what i think about this you know
but i'm curious how you think about
the risk of conceding a
future that's bad for workers when in
fact we may have democratic choices we
could make that would
make the future not unfold like that at
all
i don't think i was arguing for the
future anymore
like i just looked outside my window and
said this is here and now
this is where we are if you look around
is the precarity already here
like are americans working two or three
jobs
uh you know do school teachers have to
commute 90 minutes and
in order to like you know come teach
people's kids in rich areas and then
have uber
advertise to them that like hey we found
school teachers make good uber drivers
and parentheses we know that you can't
live just on the school teacher salary
anymore
i mean all of like the bleak [ __ ] that
people fear
is here uh now the pandemic sped it up
um and made it crystal clear but
all you have to do is look at our
legislators and say like hey have these
people been on the ball like making the
right political choices for the last x
number of years so
a lot of it on is just like like i i
just said look
[ __ ] is much bleaker and nastier right
now than most people
accept uh and as soon as you actually
scratch the surface and flip the rock
over you're like whoa
like this is actually really really dark
and punishing and inhuman and destroying
people
people's ways of life are disintegrating
right and left i spent i mean you were
from
you grew up in the midwest right for at
least a period yeah
yeah like i mean i've spent always
telling you to go back to my country and
he's like you know i'm not going back to
cleveland
yeah shake our heights i have some
friends from there so
i saw what happened to ohio you know
like the aftermath
of the decimation of manufacturing jobs
has just left a lot of those communities
in a really rough spot
it was a woman in cleveland who said to
me she said hey around here changes the
four letter word
and i had to figure out what the heck
she was talking about i was like
it's factually not but also how can you
regard change
as so negative and was only after
spending time with her she said look for
us change means the plant closing
people leaving success here in this part
of ohio means leaving
uh it's one reason why lebron coming
back was such a big deal
is that like if you just see people
deserting your
town right and left then if i say hey
we're going to change things around here
like your mind immediately goes to well
like
that's probably bad for me because any
because like i haven't seen a good
change in quite some time
so but what do you think about this
notion of
i mean what the people you're talking
about lack is both money
and power right um
by which i mean political power in
particular right so if you're that
union you know union or x ex-union
personnel in ohio sure right a
you have less money because of the
industrialization but b
like you may not have a union job
anymore or your union maybe have less
membership maybe less powerful
may have less pull all true now
my concern would be but but talk me out
of it like
my concern would be okay we start giving
that person twelve thousand dollars a
year as a
guaranteed income great does that
i'm concerned that that doesn't fix the
power
issue and that there's other problems in
their life
i'm going to pitch this to schools and
this and that that will not
just be fixed by them having more cash
in it but there's some issues that will
be
but their lack of power will still
result in and that and that it might
reduce the urgency
of dealing with what feels like the
fundamental issue
this is really important to me so number
one i'm not against
uh other things that help improve that
person's situation
you know i'm for giving them money and
i'm for easing uh
you know the ability for people to to
form unions and collectively bargain
like i'm
for ways to pay teachers more
like to me like you can be for all these
things because they're all the right
things to do
but here's the bigger thing is that
community
more empowered to actually be able to
stand in line and vote
to actually resist employer exploitation
to actually
like maybe make some investments in
their schools or volunteer their time
for their kids at the pta or like
whatnot that's right
if they have that money in their pocket
so you're also paying that's all
to be civic you're get you're giving
them the kind of space in their life to
be civic
yes like right now you know if you say
to someone who like and i've been to
these
you have too i'm sure like you're with
this person in ohio you're like hey get
out and vote
like they look at you and they're
they're like this does not [ __ ]
matter to me at all like my vote does
not matter
uh and they have in many cases like
decades of experience telling them just
that
you know and then there are people that
like will never come near it
um because uh
they're completely in despair or you
know like like
they're completely disconnected from
civic society um
and that to me is not uh extraordinary
anymore
and it's not even irrational that's the
toughest part anna you can't be like hey
if you just get your ass and vote we're
gonna fix everything it's like
actually not really like they could come
and vote and like
you know their person just gets co-opted
or their person just one vote and
like a chorus or their person like it's
um
like the power dynamics are so broken um
and then selling to them that like hey
this vote's gonna do it for you if you
just get that person into city council
or school board
it's like you know that's not true like
you know that these systems when the
person gets there
like even if they're good they're gonna
get like their hands cuffed and they're
gonna be hold behold into some [ __ ]
and then
they'll be out voted by like you know
that they're like you know crazy
uh cohort on the city council or school
board or
state legislature or us congress or
whatever it happens to be
uh the the the restoration of their
ability to make better choices
is contingent upon them actually having
like the means to
survive and be able to decide what to do
with six hours of their time
like it's ridiculous right now to go to
someone who's like destitute and like
struggling and can't make ends meet and
be like you know what i want you to do
now i want you to volunteer i want you
to vote i want you to spend this time
it's like like like a lot more and more
americans are responding with a big [ __ ]
you
like it says you know and so like to me
the big step
if you get money in those people's hands
it gets their head up
and to use an international reference
that people know it's like
if you look at countries that have more
robust social benefits
like civic engagement goes up protests
go up like you know like various things
happen where if you have some degree of
liberty
then it's not a sedative sale to the
right
give people free money and then they'll
protest more you know
well i'm just saying it's like give give
people money and they'll have actual
like energy
and visibility and the ability to
participate i'm i'm
convinced by that i think part of where
i had the you know before you were
selling it the people i most
heard in interval particularly i was
reporting the book selling this were
like silicon valley
venture capitalists whose reasons are
very different from yours who didn't say
any of the things you just said
and and if i had to summarize what i
heard from a lot of them
it was essentially let's bribe people
not to revolt
right the future is going to be bad for
these people we want a future
in which tech will be left alone won't
be regulated and which monopoly will be
able to function with impunity which
there will be wealth taxes there won't
be
higher taxes on capital gains and and
high incomes we want that future
and so let's conceive this i'm just
talking about from their point of view
like what is a way that we can get on
board
with an efficiently distributed social
program
that will be insurance they're kind of
like libertarian insurance
and like and protect our ability to keep
being us
and i know you come at it from a very
different place but that's that was the
intersection that
that always worried me but but i but i
but i hear what you're saying i think
i'm not sure maybe i didn't hear it i'm
not sure i heard you talk about this in
the
in the campaign as much which is like
this notion of
if you expect people to be civic you
need to
you need to like buy the space needed to
show you
you actually give a [ __ ] about them
because like right now we're just paying
lip service it's like hey great news
you're an american you can vote
it's like we're not gonna invest in you
your neighborhood your family or schools
in any way
and if we do invest in them we're gonna
make it ridiculously paternalistic and
like bludgeon the [ __ ] out of you and
just make you feel like
uh uh less than human being at every
step of the way
um but we love you and value and care
about it like the whole thing
you know one of the things i i compare
it to and it's like can you show up to a
company you know
within like a day whether that company
gives a [ __ ] about you you know
i mean like that like that there's like
there are companies where they
and then even when they do invest and do
all the right things some of it's
misplaced and dumb
but you can at least tell like okay
they're kind of trying it's like like
this culture means they have to at least
show that they're investing something in
their people
um in terms of like the citizenship
experience right now there are many
people that do not feel
genuinely that we are investing in them
and they're not wrong
like that this would be the biggest
reversal of that
one of the things i campaigned on was
saying uh you know imagine a
country where you could look your kids
in the eye and say your country loves
you your country values you and your
country will invest in you and your
future
like i mean does that kid actually take
civic engagement and voting much more
seriously
you know i i think so and you know it's
like it because then the government
would be doing something concrete for
them that they could understand and
you know and it's very hard to argue
with it's one of the reasons why i ran
on it was like look
like it's hard to demonize cash
like it's hard to look at and say this
cash is gonna hurt you
like it's it's one way that we can get
this thing done and then make the
changes like i think it supercharges our
ability to make the other changes
because it ends up activating people
and activates uh folks who who can then
start rolling back some of the things
that you're describing thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you